[Music]
1996
red green cable
trade trading card
anime
blue yellow n64 transfer patterns
[Music]
jack 1999
gold silver evolution
anime crystal mobile
teletrade panel puzzle
gaming device
[Music]
fire red leaf green emerald wireless
adapter
[Music]
grace
[Music]
2006 diamond pearl u.s feeling
global trade
[Music]
[Applause]
walk together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
anime
[Music]
[Music]
anime
cuteness content
um
[Music]
let's go pikachu
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
trains
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
fashion article live performance
[Music]
hello everyone i'm ishihara from the
pokemon company
february 27th is the date pokemon red
and pokemon green were released in japan
marking the beginning of the pokemon
series
an astounding 25 years have passed since
the pokemon series was born
we've shared so much with you over the
past 25 years
through our games but also through so
many other mediums
thanks to the support you've all shown
us
thank you each and every one of you
today mr uxnomia will introduce our
latest updates
hello there my name is utsunomiya from
the pokemon company
first i'd like to give you the latest
update on the new pokemon snap game
we've put together a video that will
show you some of the gameplay please
have a look
[Music]
welcome to the worlds of new pokemon
snap
this is the lentil region you'll ride
the neo one
through the jungle across the desert
and even under the sea to research
pokemon in their natural habitats
and of course you won't be alone
professor mir who's doing research in
the lentil region
and research team members rita and phil
are there to support you
so you're in good hands
now then let's get that research started
by watching wild pokemon you can
discover behaviors and expressions
that are rarely seen look a surfing
alolan ride you
there's vaporeon let's try throwing in a
fluff fruit
that's it now's our chance
[Music]
oh it's tyranitar what a wild way to eat
here's a park at night let's try playing
a melody
oh that sure made who hoo-hoot happy
[Music]
you'll also have illumina orbs something
the professor
invented if you use one of these you can
make any pokemon glow
whoa those flames changed color
[Music]
make good use of your tools to take
shots that really stand out
then show the photos you took to the
professor
oh four stars we captured a rare moment
there
catch a variety of different behaviors
on camera
to fill up your pokemon photo decks and
there's more
you'll be able to edit the photos you've
taken
use features like stickers and frames to
make your favorite photos
even more special and i'm sure you'll
want to show off your
best photos right we know that feeling
well
when you want to do that it's time to go
online
you can share your favorite photos and
check out photos from around the world
and if your photo becomes popular it
might even be featured
and get more attention seeing something
like that may inspire you to go back
and take even more photos we're getting
closer to the start of your adventure
unexplored islands and plenty of pokemon
await in the lentil region
so make sure you're prepared
[Music]
whoa is that the mythical pokemon celebi
get ready the lentil region is waiting
for you
[Music]
what did you think i hope you're looking
forward to the game's release
on april 30th
[Music]
next i'd like to tell you about several
events we're holding to celebrate
pokemon day
in the pokemon sword and pokemon shield
games
special max raid battles featuring
gigantomax pikachu
are underway
and in pokemon cafe mix we're holding a
promotion in which you can receive 2500
golden acorns
for logging in in pokemon go
articuno zapdos moltres and even mewtwo
are appearing in legendary raid battles
as part of a kanto themed celebration
event
in pokemon masters ex gala region
champion leon
and his partner pokemon charizard will
arrive at last
we hope you'll enjoy these events next
i'd like to present the latest news
about the pokemon video game series
have a look at this video
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this is a tale from a long long time ago
when the sinnoh region was still only a
vast wilderness
[Music]
a certain village bustled with the
comings and goings of people
while in the mountains and seas pokemon
roamed as they pleased
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm pleased to announce two new
additions to the pokemon video game
series
both taking place in the sinnoh region
first i'd like to present the pokemon
brilliant diamond and pokemon shining
pearl games
these are faithful remakes of the
pokemon diamond version and pokemon
pearl version games
which were released for the nintendo ds
system in japan
15 years ago
[Music]
the pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl games
remakes of the pokemon diamond version
and pokemon pearl version games which
were released for the nintendo ds system
are coming to nintendo's switch
[Music]
games will be developed by ilka inc who
also worked on pokemon home
the project is being directed by yuichi
ueda of ilka
as well as game freak's junichi masuda
who is the director for the original
pokemon diamond version
and pokemon pro version games your
adventure will take place in the sinnoh
region
rich in nature and with towering mount
coronet at its heart
it is a land of many myths passed down
through the ages
the sense of scale of the original
game's towns and roots
has been carefully preserved and you'll
be able to travel through familiar
locations once again
you'll set out on your journey after
choosing either turtwig
chimchar or piplup as your first partner
pokemon
in these games you can enjoy a grand
adventure together
with all the pokemon from pokemon
diamond version
and pokemon pearl version newcomers and
previous visitors to the sinnoh region
alike
can look forward to experiencing the
original pokemon diamond and pokemon
pearl stories
freshly recreated for nintendo switch
what did you think pokemon brilliant
diamond and pokemon shining pearl will
launch
simultaneously around the world late
this year
we hope you're all excited for a
nostalgic yet fresh adventure in the
sinnoh region
next allow me to introduce you to the
pokemon legends
arceus game pokemon legends arceus
represents a new approach for the
pokemon video game series
development is in full swing at game
freak with the aim to deliver a gaming
experience that breaks new ground for
the pokemon series
please have a look at this video
the events of this game unfold in the
sinnoh of
old in this time too mount coronet
towers over the center of the region
pokemon live freely in the wild here but
the harsh environments may be different
from the sinnoh region
you remember in this era
people have journeyed to sinnoh from all
over and founded a prosperous village in
the hope of learning
more about this land as for these three
pokemon
rowlet cyndaquil and oshawatt it seems
they were brought to sinnoh by a certain
professor
who encountered them while traveling
around various regions
you'll set off on your adventure after
receiving a first partner pokemon of
your own
from this professor
[Music]
with the village as your base you'll
venture out to the different corners of
the region
on your quest to create cinno's very
first pokedex
even in this era wild pokemon can be
caught with pokeballs
you can also engage in pokemon battles
alongside your pokemon allies
sharpen your skills for both catching
and battling pokemon and strive to
complete your pokedex
now for the mythical pokemon that graces
the game's title and story
arceus according to legend archie has
shaped all there is in this world
but how is this pokemon connected to
your journey
the answer to this question and more
awaits you in this exciting new action
rpg
adventure for the nintendo switch system
[Music]
pokemon legends arceus will launch
simultaneously around the world early
next year
we hope you're all excited to set out on
these adventures across the sinnoh
region
each one distinctly different from the
other with the wonderfully nostalgic
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining
pearl as well as the pokemon video game
series new journey
pokemon legends arceus
as pokemon celebrates 25 years we will
continue to challenge ourselves
and deliver new ways for everyone to
enjoy pokemon even more
thank you very much for watching
you